alles nur keine atomkraft bisher steht
das nein zur laufzeitverlängerung der
atomkraftwerke von spd den grünen und
umweltverbänden aber stimmen die anti
akw argumente ueberhaupt wir machen den
lügen checkte atomkraftgegner behauptung
1 deutschland hat kein strom sondern ein
wärme problem das sagt unter anderem
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck fakt
ist aber je mehr gas zur stromproduktion
verwendet wird desto weniger bleibt zum
heizen und wenn die atomkraftwerke am
netz bleiben produzieren sie sechs
prozent für die stromproduktion und so
bleibt mehr gas behauptung 2 der
sicherheitscheck der atomkraftwerke
dauert zu lange fakt ist die
atomkraftwerke werden regelmäßig checkt
und ein tüv gutachten aus dem märz 2022
sagt dass die werke mit nur wenigen
maßnahmen weiter betrieben werden können
behauptung 3 der gesellschaftliche
wandel zum akw aus darf nicht aufs spiel
gesetzt werden aber lautes insa
instituts sind 64 prozent der
bundesbürger für eine längere laufzeit
der haupt um vier neue brennstäbe seien
nicht rechtzeitig da fakt ist die
brennstäbe können auch über ihr
vorgesehenes ablaufdatum funktionieren
der tüv sagt das ist möglich behauptung
es gebe nicht genug personal aber das
gleiche problem gibt es bei
kohlekraftwerken genauso die aktuell von
wirtschaftsminister habe ich wieder
hochgefahren werden
[Musik]